fresh let's get to let's get to you how
have you been in love have you been in
love exactly no
do you guys believe in love do you guys
believe in love
uh you know what it is i look at it
logically because like for me for
example
i can see that there is consideration
there's definitely emotional connections
100 however i'm not going to put myself
in a situation where i can actually like
take an advantage of so for example i
meet someone right we connect on a
certain level we have understanding but
i'll never like say oh i live so much
because i'm going to give you everything
off rip i'm going to see who you are
over a period of time and you will tell
me who you are and i can either cut the
rope there right there and then or keep
it going when you say give you
everything do you mean like financials
assets or like you give you all of you
well uh in terms of like financials like
for example someone sometimes you're
talking about tangibles somebody say i
love you right and they'll do whatever
they can for you but that's just like
auto like maybe i guess lust or maybe
like you know a feeling versus okay
logically speaking i want to see who you
are over a period of time so i'm going
to see who you are and then from that
point i can determine if you're right or
die if you're here for a moment and i
can logically say you know what cool
i'll invest more or less but you never
even had a taste of that at this point
in your life no i know girls that loved
me no you you haven't had that feeling
of like like that drug under drug
feeling
the serotonin coming through your brain
like all logic goes out the window have
you had that where you just absolutely
want this person every day all day
no it's there but i also can say to
myself okay cool that feeling is there
but it goes and comes
[Music]